when I was in kindergarten want to be an
astronaut you know like that things
change but I still kind of wish I had
followed that you know pursued that
astronaut life I know that makes one of
us
hi I'm Vanessa and I'm Mandy my name is
Ted and I'm Ryan and today we're
answering anonymous questions from
students students middle school in high
school dealing with you know teenagers
there are a lot of questions about my
personal life that I had to steer away
from so the type of questions I hope are
not asked are going to be about my
personal life you don't need to know
about me you don't want them to get
everything from me you want to walk in
and be a little mysterious as a
preschool teacher I hope my children are
asking questions because then that means
that they're wondering about life and
that's just our bread and butter on the
flip side of that they are very honest
teacher why are your teeth yellow I'm
just like I'm also not going to tell any
of them my social security number I try
to keep that private but sometimes it
slips out did you always want to become
a teacher did you change your mind later
on in life I started wanting to be a
teacher when I was in high school I
think a lot of the reason I became a
teacher was because I really like
working with young people I got the
teacher bug also in high school I was
doing some National Honor Society
volunteering tutoring and I loved that I
still remember the names of the teachers
that were great you know like shouts out
to mr. truck when you know what's up man
seventh grade where you at I miss you
people like that they make a big they
have a big lasting effect in your life
and we want to make that sort of impact
I had some great teachers that were
really inspiring but I also had some
terrible teachers so there was almost
like a deep part of me that was like I
can do this so much better than you I
never saw those teachers again but they
know do teachers ever shift
students together basically mentally
pairing them together romantically I
could tell sometimes when there was a
crush either both ways I don't think I
ever like looked at a classroom of
students
oh those two sitting next to each other
and start start their romance
you guys would be so cute together like
15 years I have thought about that like
Oh in the future like you guys might be
a thing when a student has unreadable
handwriting
do you really grade their essay or do
you give them a grade based off of past
performance and participation in class
or something question mark no I do not
give them a grade based off past
performance most of my students are
writing essays on a computer anyway
now they have unreadable grammar that's
a different story I would try to set it
aside and ask the student to explain
whatever it was they were trying to say
I'm working with one student and you
know that she willingly admitted that
she has like unreadable completely
illegible handwriting and I saw it and
that's true but what I told her was like
you just need to slow down and try to
write bigger because I had the exact
same problem and I was in elementary
school I failed my preschoolers all the
time I can't read this what is this
why do teachers ask questions to the
class and then call on the students who
don't have their hands up it's cuz we're
mean if I notice that there's a student
that isn't really wanting to participate
I may call on them just to engage them
kind of bring them back to the group you
gotta make sure everyone's engaged and
paying attention and keep kids on their
toes and on top of their game it would
be really boring if just the same two
kids who are always answered a question
for answering the questions what are
your opinions on the quiet kids they're
my favorite students zip it
sit down that's it it's tough to know a
lot about the kids that just sit there
and they're quiet even the ones that
like do their work those are the ones
that you like hope that you catch them
like they need to come in and lunch and
ask a question and you kind of like
figure out a little bit more about them
it's important to like know why they're
quiet if it's something at home you know
you
you want to find out about that so you
can let the right people know and get
them help if they need it if they're
just a quiet person just cuz they don't
want to talk or something like that
that's fine too but it's important to
like find out the sort of the root cause
do teachers know all the drama and tea
that goes on in the greater class they
teach do teachers talk bad about
students to other teachers there's how a
young little three-year-old drama I
worked with summer camps before and we
know some of that she's myth the only
time I knew of stuff going on was when
it impacted things in class so whether
someone was crying or if there was a
fight we would ask you know why are you
crying or whatever and try to help them
I wouldn't say that we talked bad to one
another it's more hey I heard this what
can we do to help this child I'm not
proud to say it but in middle school in
high school there were kids that were
jerks and so you know like we would say
like oh my goodness I have this kid this
hour and it's rough you know like we
wouldn't say anything super
mean-spirited we just need to vent
defense and sometimes two would be kind
of like do you have any ideas how I can
make this better or your teacher support
team is just essential I like this
question a lot it says are there ever
times you don't know what you're doing
yes the important thing isn't like
whether or not you know what you're
doing it's that you're projecting that
air of confidence you sometimes have you
know you have your lesson plans things
inevitably go off the rails maybe the
kids are not as far along as you thought
they were gonna be at that point so you
need to improvise it's part of being a
teacher have you ever noticed if a kid
has a problem like ADHD depression etc
before the parents or maybe even the kid
if yes did you ever do anything about it
yes and yes I definitely had experiences
where the kid wasn't getting the proper
treatment or care that they should
there's definitely been times where like
so late in the process I've been like
hey this this kid probably has an issue
since I work with children at such a
young age I've had to do this many a
time we try to be as sensitive to the
families as possible but also really
trying to get them
understand that we have their children's
best interests at heart do you guys
genuinely like to know what all students
who ever participate somebody has a chip
on their shoulder there's always that
one student who will raise their hand
every time or they just say it without
even oh boy I'm gonna nip that in the
bud participation is always great but
it's important to make sure everybody's
participating if you're shouting out the
answer every single time I ask a
question then no one else is gonna be
able to try to like participate or
figure it out those are the kids where
I'm like hey I'm sure you know the
answer I believe that you know the
answer but let's give somebody else what
you guys how about somebody else does
this I like whoever wrote this is like I
think has to be like no we don't we hate
them nope this is the one the one who
wrote that is the know-it-all in writing
class I hope this was illuminating I was
pretty surprised by how serious the
questions were I thought they were going
to be so many embarrassing questions in
here I was like oh gosh let's see what
they have for us but I actually really
enjoyed answering these questions we are
trying to help you and help you do your
best
we genuinely care about you we want you
to do well we're new we're probably
pretty nervous it takes some getting
used to so be cool to your new teachers
there you never know what battles
someone's fighting so just remember to
be kind yeah don't make fun of other
kids shoes you can make fun of the
teachers shoes you can try my shoes at
my shoe games on point you have a good
shoe game I shop at Marshall's
[Music]